مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل العسكري
لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه وفيها
نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فايز دويري
اهلا بك لواء دويري ونتابع بدايه اخر
تطورات المشهد ميدانيا على الخريطه
تفاعليه مع سلام خضر اليك سلام شكرا وسيله
الوضع مشتعل الى حد بعيد اليوم سنبدا بان
القتال عاد الى جميع مناطق قطاع غزه من
الشمال الى الجنوب في خطوه ربما كثيرون لم
يكونوا يتوقعوها قبل ان نبدا بالقتال
اليوم رشقت صاروخيتين انطلقتا من داخل
قطاع غزه قبل بضع دقائق سرايا القدس قالت
انها استهدفت عده مناطق في غلاف غزه وقبل
ذلك بنحو ساعتين او اكثر كانت كتائب
القسام ايضا قد اعلنت عن استهداف
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في غلاف غزه برشقه
صاروخيه نعود الى شمال القطاع قالت
اسرائيل
انها انهت الوجود العسكري لحركه لكتائب
القسام وحركات المقاومه في الشمال منذ
اكثر من اسبوع وكررت هذا الامر وتقول ان ل
ان حركات المقاومه لم تستطع قادره على
التحرك في المنطقه الشماليه المحاذيه
تماما للحدود من الجانبين سواء الحدود
الشماليه او الشرقيه اليوم اكثر من نقطه
عادت للاشتعال في المنطقه الشماليه
اشتباكات عنيفه في اكثر من محور بين كتائب
القسام وبين القوات الاسرائيليه علما ان
اسرائيل قالت انها سحبت قواتها ويفترض
انها تحدثت عن انها ستبدا بتخفيف القوات
الموجوده واول الاماكن التي اعادت تموضع
القوات منها كانت المنطقه الشماليه هنا
نتحدث ايضا عن ما قالت عنه الفورين بوليسي
قالت ربما انه لدى اسرائيل خطابين الخطاب
الاول تتوجه به الى الولايات المتحده و
الخطاب الثاني تتحدث به الى الاسرائيليين
في الداخل في اشاره الى انه قد لا تكون
جاهزه بعد قوات الاحتلال على سحب قوتها
وتغيير نمط العمليات في المنطقه الوسطى
ايضا القتال اليوم كان مشتعلا عند اكثر من
نقطه وكان هناك استهدافات
لتجمعات وايضا ل اليات اسرائيليه ولكن
النقطه الاساسيه دير البلح تحاول القوات
الاسرائيليه كما بات واضحا ال الدخول الى
دير البلح وتشن هجمات عليه رغم انها ما
زالت ايضا تقاتل عند محور المخيمات انسرات
البريج المغازي ولكن من الواضح ان هناك
توجه لاختراق دير البلح و ننتقل الى جنوب
القطاع الى منطقه خان يونس بالتحديد خان
يونس والمناطق المجاوره تشهد قتالا لا
يزال مستمرا على اكثر من ناحيه وفي اكثر
من نقطه السبب في ان القتال لا يزال
مستمرا في الاستراتيجيات العسكريه دوما
هناك مقوله بان قتال الانفاق هو
اصعب المناطق والاكثر تعقيدا عندما تتواجد
انفاق وهناك مقارنات بين القتال في
المناطق قطاع غزه وبين ما جرى في فيتنام
اليوم ما زالت خان يونس في قلب المعركه
ولكن هناك ايضا استهدافات مكثفه ف اللافت
اليوم في المنطقه الجنوبيه هي كثره
الاستهدافات من قبل كتائب المقاومه هناك
تفجير فتوحات نفق هناك هجمات على جنود
اسرائيليين عند اكثر من منطقه وهناك ايضا
اعاده تموضع اسرائيليه في هذا المكان
ثمانيه الويه تقاتل الويه مدرعات وايضا
الويه مشاه ولواء مظليين ووحده هندسيه
خاصه لتفكيك الانفاق حتى الان لم تستطع
الانهاء او القضاء على على مساله اساسيه
وهي استدراج الجنود الاسرائيليين الى
مناطق تتواجد فيها فتوحات انفاق وهميه
لتفجير هذه الفتوحات رغم ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول بانه استولى او فجر 300
نفق
واستهدف 700 منصه صواريخ وغير ذلك اليوم
في اليوم نحن نقترب من انهاء اليوم المئه
لهه الحرب نرى ان القطاع برمته من الشمال
الى الجنوب اعاد فش شعل وايضا ما زالت
كتائب المقاومه قادره على استهداف غلاف
غزه وربما ابعد اليوم هناك استهداف في
غلاف غزه في الايام السابقه راينا
استهدافات وصلت الى تل ابيب نختم بنقطه
انه اليوم ايضا الفورن بوليسي نشرت تحقيقا
قالت ان الجيش الاسرائيلي لم يعتمد
النصيحه الامريكيه بعدم التوغل الى قطاع
غزه لسببين النصيحه اتت من تجربه العراق
وتجربه افغانستان يقول يقول الكاتب ان
هاتين التجربتين خسرت فيهما الكثير
الولايات المتحده والمساله الثانيه يتحدث
عن طبيعه الجيش الاسرائيلي وقربه من
الديموغرافيا الاسرائيليه فانه يقاتل بغير
ما تقاتل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وسيله هذه ابرز التطورات الميدانيه
القراءه بطبيعه الحال مع لواء دويري شكرا
جزيلا لك سلام لواء دويري نحن على عتبه
اليوم
المئه من هذه الحرب مثل ما قالت السلام
المعارك على اشدها القتال ضاري في
مختلف مناطق لنبدا بالجنوب الذي يشهد قصف
كبير ان كان في خانيونس او رفح خان يونس
على وجه التحديد كيف نقرا مسار المعارك
المعركه في خان يونس مختلفه كليا عن
المعركه في منطقه المخيمات الوسط ومختلفه
عما جرى في القاطع الشمالي بسبب تاثير الج
الجغرافي
والديموغرافيا هذه المنطقه تعتبر منطقه
واسعه جدا نحن نتحدث عن قطاع غزه لا نتحدث
عن بلدان واسعه ذات مساحه كبيره نتحدث عن
262 م العمق هنا 14 م بينما العمق في شمال
القراره 6.5 ك م وبالتالي هذه كانها ضعف
المساحه اذا نظرنا الى الخط الاخر من
القراره حتى رف كذلك تعتبر منطقه واسعه
اثنين المباني فيها ليست متلاصقه كما كانت
في حال مدينه غزه يعني القاطع الشمالي
عندما نقول مدينه غزه تشمل تقريبا غالبيه
القطاع باستثناء المناطق الزراعيه لا اذا
نظرنا الى عبسان و عبسان الجديده وبن سيله
والزن والقرار نجد هناك مساحات بينيه هذه
المساحات انعكست على طبيعه شبكه الانفاق
وعلى عدد الفتحات وعلى بالتالي اداره
المعركه لهذا السبب نجد ان ال قوات جيش
الاحتلال رغم انه عدل في شكل المناوره
باكثر من مقاربه في البدايه دخل من كوس
فيم والى شمال القراره وانعطف الى المطاحن
الى مدينه الحمد الى المواصي الى جوش قطيف
ومنها استطاع ان يدخل الى ثلاثه نقاط داخل
مدينه غزه مضى على دخوله اكثر من ثمانيه
ايام لا تزال هي النقاط لم يستطع ان يتثبت
بها ولم يستطع ان يطور عملياته المقاربه
الثانيه كانت بمحاوله المهاجمه من شمال
الزنه من شمال عبسان الجديده ومن جنوب
عبسان الكبيره حقق نجاحات وصل الى ما
يقارب شارع صلاح الدين لكنه لم يستطع ان
يدخل الى المنطقه الفاصله ما بين اتجاهي
الهجوم عدل مره ثالثه وحاول ان ان ان يذهب
بهجوم من منطقه الفخار
باتجاه خان يونس فشلت المحاوله المحاوله
الرابعه كانت بالتوجه او بالعوده الى
القراره الى ومنطقه الزنه قاتل فيها لمده
خمسه ايام دمر مظاهر الحياه لكنه لم يستطع
ان يسيطر عليها فتم سحب القوات كامله الى
السياجي وما وراء السياج لاعاده تاهيل
القوات واستخدامها وقد يكون استخدامها في
دير البلح اخر تطور كان اللي هو دفاع مره
اخرى من المنطقه الجنوبيه من جنوب عبسان
الكبيره الى قازان النجار وا احدث تماس مع
مدينه خان يونس ووصل الى كليه العلوم
التطبيقيه في تلك المنطقه ولا يزال متواجد
والقتال يجري في هذه المنطقه هذه صوره
عامه عن معركه الجنوب واللافت كذلك ان
اليوم القصف المدفعي يشتد بشكل كبير على
خان يونس المقاومه في اكثر من فيديو اكدت
استهدافها
للجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قتل جنديين
قائدي كتيبه واسقاط مروحيه كذلك الى اي او
الى ماذا يؤشر كل هذا يعني الان القتال
اشتد ولكن حتى الحديث عن الخسائر تراجع
سواء في بيانات الناطق او حتى الافلام
التي تاتي نلاحظ كثافتها اقل من الايام
السابقه لماذا لانه اجرى كذلك تعديلا على
اداره المعركه الان يعتمد ب
رئيسيه يعني هو لا يرغب في حدوث الصدام
المباشر يتجنب الصدام المباشر قدر الامكان
فوظفون قبل اسبوعين بدا باستخدام الروبوت
سواء الروبوت الذي يطلق اصوات او الروبوت
المقاتل استخدم كذلك طائرات الطائرات
الدرون الصغيره الكوات كابتور وس والان
توظيف في بعدين في البعد الاستطلاعي وفي
بعد وفي البعد القتالي كذلك وظف القناصين
فبالتالي ادوات الاشتباك الان هي مع
الطائرات المسيره لهذا نلاحظ انه ازدادت
عدد الطائرات التي تسقط باستخدام الروبوت
باستخدام القناصين بعد ان يتاكد بان
المنطقه شده المقاومه بها انخفضت يدفع
بالقوات من اجل الالتحام المباشر والتطير
النهائي و كل ما ذكرته يدخل في اطار
الاساليب الحديثه مثل ما قال الجيش
الاسرائيلي التي يستخدمها فيما يتعلق
بالروبوت الى اي مدى كان استخدامه ناجع
وكيف انعكس على المي هو الان
الروبوت جيش الاحتلال لم يتحدث عن استخدام
الروبوت الذي كشف الامر تحدث عن استخدام
اساليب حديثه وس ن من ضمنها الروبوت انا
اجيب عن الروبوت مباشره لانه الروبوت
استخدم في بثلاثه ابعاد استخدم بداخل
الانفاق واستخدم
ك من اجل عمليات الخداع المقاتلين لان
يصدر اصوات واصوات اطلاق نيران مشابهه
للدبابه واستخدم الروبوت المقاتل قلت لك
اضاف عليها اكثر من يعني فيما يتعلق بالفا
بالانفاق استخدم الكلاب بصوره مضافه
استخدم القناصين فبالتالي هي الاضافات
التي بدا ي استخدامها وتكثيف استخدام
الطائرات العمود
الاباتشي او طائرات الدرون هي جميعها من
اجل احداث اقصى ضرر ممكن وخفض القدره
القتاليه للقوات المدافعه حتى يتمكن من
دفع قوات ورغم ذلك لم يخفض القدره
القتاليه للمقاومه لاسما في الشمال التي
قال انه قضى فيها على حماس وانهى العمليه
الكبرى دعنا فقط نتوقف عند هذا الفيديو
ونعود للتحليل حيث بثت كتائب القسام صورا
لاطلاق رشقه صاروخيه من قطاع غزه باتجاه
اسرائيل وقد افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
صافرات الانذار تدوي في ناتيف عسرا في
غلاف غزه الشمالي نتابع هذا
[موسيقى]
الفيديو هذا اذا الفيديو لواء دويري الذي
نشرتها كتائب القسام للرشق
الصاروخيه باتجاه غلاف غزه يعني هذا
الفيديو بعد كما تحدث سلام تم
رايا القدس اطلقت صواريخ مماثله لكن
جميعها باتجاه غلاف غزه بعتقد يعني الان
اطلاق الصواريخ صار لم يعد الهدف منه كما
كان في اليوم الاول او كما كان في
الاسابيع
الاولى اللي هو احداث الضرر الا في حالات
النادره عندما تط ما الهدف منه الان الان
الهدف منه رساله سياسيه والرد على
التصريحات المسولين الاسرائيليين انه دانت
السيطره على القاطع الشمالي قد قتلنا 9000
من اصل 14000 لم لن يستطيعوا ان يخوضوا
معركه دفاعيه فتاتي الاجابات بالاشتباكات
الارضيه وباطلا الصواريخ الاشتباكات
الارضيه واجابه على سؤالك التقارير التي
وردت انه تم سحب الفرقه 162 و252 وتم
سحبها الى خارج غلاف غزه الى غلاف غزه
خارج القطاع على عمق 5 الى 15 م ولكن هذا
لا يمنع ان تعود لا يمنع اذا توف فرت
معلومات عن وجود اهداف تستحق للعوده
اكتشاف
انفاق حديث عن رهائن او ظهور مقاتلين يتم
دفع قوات جديده فبالتالي تستمر الاشتباكات
والمعارك مع القوات التي تدخل وهذه دخولها
مؤطر زمانا ومكانا لتحقيق اهداف محدده
وليس ل عكس صوره المرحله الاولى من
المعركه لكن هذا التواجد هو كثيف جدا الان
في وادي غزه في
عرضه 1 م م وبعمق 5 م م شكرا جزيلا لك
لواء فايز ادوير المحلل العسكري
والاستراتيجي